this episode is brought to you by tonal
t-o-n-a-l
i'm super excited about this one and i
was skeptical
of it in the beginning tonal quote tonal
is the world's most intelligent home gym
and personal trainer end quote that's
the tagline
from their website folks to give you the
one sentence summary and
this device it's really a system is
perfect for anyone looking to take their
home workouts to the next level or
someone who just wants to get maximum
bang for the buck
in a tiny tiny footprint of space
tonal is precision engineered to be the
world's most advanced strength studio
and personal trainer it uses
breakthrough technology of all different
types
to help get you stronger faster i was
introduced to tonal by three different
friends all of them are tech savvy
one of them is a former competitive
skier who's doubled his strength in a
number of movements using tonal even
though he has a
long athletic background and i'll paint
a picture for you by eliminating
traditional metal weights dumbbells and
barbells tonal can deliver 200 pounds of
resistance which doesn't sound like a
lot but it's actually
it feels like a lot more at the high end
in a device smaller than a flat screen
tv and you can perform at least 150
different exercises and these different
technologies are exclusive to tonal and
you can dial weights up and down
with the touch of a button in one pound
increments using magnets and electricity
so the movement is extremely smooth
and even though i have a home gym
already in my garage i'm still getting a
tonal installed i've used
tonal for multiple workouts now to do
things i just cannot do
in my home gym such as the chop and lift
exercises from the four hour body all
sorts of cable exercises that would
usually
involve much much bigger piece of
equipment eccentric
training for instance you can do to give
a simple example
bicep curls where you are lifting let's
just say
20 pounds in each hand up and then tonal
will automatically
increase the weight because you can
lower more than you can lift to say
25 or 30 pounds on the way down and i do
kettlebell swings i do all sorts of
deadlifts this that and the other thing
and after one workout
on tonal focusing on pulling i was
blasted for a full
week it's really incredible what you can
do with eccentrics
they also have all sorts of other really
really cool
advantages that you can apply to any of
your favorite movements
tonal learns from your strength and
provides suggested weight
recommendations for every move with
detailed progress reports to help you
see your strengths grow
tonal also has a growing library of
expert-led workouts by motivating
coaches from strength training
to cardio so you can do really just
about everything every program is
personalized
to your body using artificial
intelligence and other
aspects of the engineering and smart
features check your form in real time
just like a personal trainer
so try it out try tonal at least check
it out watch
the videos on youtube and see if you can
pick out a familiar voice
it's not me i'll say that but try tonal
the world's smartest home gym
for 30 days in your home and if you
don't love it you can return it for a
full refund
so visit www.tonal.com
for 100 off of smart accessories when
you use promo code tim
tim at checkout that's www.tonal.com
promo code tim tonal be your strongest
this episode is brought to you by
givewell.org
tis the season of giving and you've got
this week and next
to make your charitable donations before
we close the books on 2020.
2021 is just around the corner that's
why i've been talking to you
on this podcast about givewell.org for
more than 10 years
givewell.org has helped donors find the
charities and projects that save
and improve lives most per dollar here's
how
givewell dedicates more than 20 000
hours a year to researching charitable
organizations
and handpicks a few of the highest
impact evidence-backed
charities i recommend to givewell.org
and they shared a note with me
which is just incredible and here it is
quote here are the data they sent me a
spreadsheet
we have from organic donations that
cited tim over the past few years
transactions that specifically cited tim
ferriss sum to 133 000
40 and 74 cents we estimate that those
donations will save
15 to 24 lives how did this happen
i suspect that a lot of these donations
came from my interview with will
mccaskill who really knows what he's
talking about when it comes to effective
giving he's a philosopher
ethicist and one of the originators of
the effective altruism movement
he is an associate professor in
philosophy at oxford
that is the university of oxford and a
researcher at the global priorities
institute at oxford just a great guy
overall
and in our podcast together he
recommended givewell
by far as one of the best places to give
if you want to make an impact especially
if
you're busy it came to his mind
immediately all of their research is
publicly available for free on their
website
and more importantly givewell never
takes any fees so
all of your tax deductible donations are
given to the charity you
choose since 2010 givewell has helped
more than 50
000 donors direct more than 500 million
dollars to the most
effective charities these donations will
save more than 75 000 lives
and improve the lives of millions more
you only have a few days left
to make tax deductible donations before
the new year so go
right now and when you make your first
donation to give well
your gift will be matched up to 250
dollars
just go to givewell.org tim
and pick podcast and tim ferriss at
checkout
you got to do those things so they can
track it this matching offer is good for
as long as funds last
so the race goes to the swift he who
hesitates or she who hesitates is lost
get your first donation matched up to
250
at givewell.org tim
and select podcast and tim ferriss at
checkout one more time
definitely take a look at this
givewell.org
tim at this altitude i can run flat out
for a half mile before my hand starts
shaking
can i answer your personal question
[Music]
i'm a cybernetic organism living tissue
over metal endoscopy
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is tim ferriss and welcome to
another episode of the tim ferriss show
my guest today
is a friend leo babauta b-a-b-a-u-t-a
on twitter at zen underscore habits
zenhabits.net he is founder of zen
habits a website dedicated to finding
simplicity and mindfulness in the daily
chaos of our lives
zen habits has more than 2 million
readers that is a lot
and time magazine has named it one of
its
top 25 blogs and top 50 websites
leo we could talk for many hours this is
just a round one
but welcome to the show it's nice to
have you on finally yeah it's great to
be here it's a
huge honor honestly and i
figured for people who don't have
contacts we could start at the beginning
or i should say maybe just the beginning
of
a transition of sorts and i'd like to
flash back to
more than 10 years ago and i want you to
correct the timing if i'm not getting it
just right but around 2005
prior to zen habits the phenomenon prior
to the best-selling books
prior to all of that could you paint a
picture of
of where you were what you were doing
your circumstances and situation at the
time
that was definitely a difficult period
in my life and really
it feels like a whole different lifetime
ago different person
but 2005 i was married with a huge
family mixed family
five kids with one more on the way in a
job i didn't like
i was overweight i was a smoker
sedentary
kept trying to change a lot of these
habits i was a big procrastinator
very deeply in debt and really not being
able to pay my bills
and just really felt stuck and felt
really bad about myself
which i think a lot of people can relate
to some aspect of that story
it was just really tough for me having
to provide for people but
not being able to make ends meet feeling
terrible about myself as a father
not a good example and just feeling
really discouraged about my ability to
make any change stick
in my life so that's where i was in
2005.
and geographically oh yeah at the time
i was in the island of guam which is
where
we're from me and my family so we start
there
this is this is almost like a screenplay
we start there and what happens
over the subsequent handful of
years or the catalyst
so to speak for some of your successful
changes what
what actually happened that was the
impetus
or the the spark so to speak for some of
the subsequent changes
you know that people say sometimes you
have to hit rock bottom before you can
climb out of it so i hit a number of
really deep
low points for myself one of them was as
i talked about debt
just not being able to put food on the
table for my family and
i remember one heartbreaking moment of
that
depth was when i had to break open my
kids piggy bank to be able to put some
like
milk and cereal on the table and so that
was a real dark point where i felt like
a failure as a father
smoking as well my wife was pregnant so
she quit smoking
while she was pregnant but i knew that
she was going to start again
as soon as she gave birth so i had to
quit
in order to set an example for her but i
also knew that my kids were much more
likely
to smoke and so i had to quit for them
as well
and there were just a number of points
where i just felt despair
and like a failure and i felt like i had
to save my life
and so i think that was the realization
was like i am
killing myself in a lot of different
ways and i'm failing myself and failing
my family
that was the most heartbreaking part was
that i was failing my wife and kids
and so from that like heartbreak
and feeling of despair and like i was
killing myself
i realized i had to reach for a lifeline
i had to do something to save my life
and my family as well and so i
decided i couldn't change all of these
things at once i was trying to
multiple times so i decided to just
change one thing
and it was smoking so i committed to
that in a really big way to a lot of
different people to my daughter
to my wife made a promise that really
felt meaningful to me
and i did a bunch of research found out
a bunch of different techniques and
tried them all
that's when i tried meditation as a
replacement
for smoking for stress so i started
meditating i started running
because i needed to do something when i
felt like i needed to smoke
and so i finally i actually made the
smoking habit
stick that i'd quit smoking for the
first time in my life i had tried like
seven times before
and that felt like a huge success and so
i felt so much encouragement from that i
felt like i could take on
the rest of the things and so one thing
at a time i started changing everything
about my life i started eating healthier
i started running more
ran a 5k i committed to running a
marathon that's how optimistic i was
after running the 5k
i started waking up earlier started
writing after wanting to write for years
procrastinating less my wife and i made
a plan to get out of debt and one small
debt at a time
we started paying them off until like a
year later
my entire life was changed i lost 30
pounds in a year
my whole life was different and i ran a
marathon
at the end of 2006 and i felt like such
a huge success
and i had learned a bunch of things that
changed those habits along the way
one after the other i apply the same
ideas to changing those habits
and that's when i started zen habits to
share all of those things that i've been
learning
let's zoom in on a few aspects of this
sure
it sounds like you know on some level
almost a cinderella story right like
everything was wrong and then 12 months
later
you were able to address so much of it
and
let's double click on the smoking
because
i know that that seems to have been a
huge point of leverage
and also a proof of concept and also a
proof of confidence
in a sense for you and you you mentioned
you'd attempted to quit seven times
before yeah
and i'd love for you to expand on
what made the eighth attempt successful
like why did this attempt succeed
when the others had failed it was such a
pivotal
moment in my life so i'm really glad
you're zooming in on this one
a number of things changed but the first
one was that
i had a very meaningful reason
something that that mattered to me and
again i mentioned my wife
and my kids making a promise to my
daughter i think before that it was only
promises to myself which i never really
keep
or i didn't at that time i didn't trust
myself to keep those promises
and so making a promise to someone else
and really feeling like this was
for something that mattered saving their
lives as well as mine
so i really got clear on that and felt
it in my heart and that really started
everything else because it
it motivated me to make a big commitment
i joined a forum online so i had some
social accountability
social accountability was turned out to
be a big one not only for this but for
all future habits
i learned about triggers and so what are
the things that triggered me to smoke
i really zoomed in on those things
stress
and anxiety and feeling bad about myself
and
being overwhelmed all of these things
really i got clear that they were the
things that caused me to smoke
or triggered me to want to smoke i also
learned
to just recognize when i had the urge
and then sit with that urge so it was a
form of meditation
is just sitting with a physical
sensation of needing to smoke
without needing to actually smoke so i
learned to separate the urge from the
action
before that whenever the urge happened i
had to take action it felt like a
command
like there was no choice and there was
no separation between them but when i
learned to separate the two
i learned that the urge is just a
feeling in my body that i could sit with
and it would rise and get really strong
and feel
incredibly urgent but then it would pass
and so
learning that actually unlocked so much
for me because i learned that
none of the urges that i need that i
thought i needed to act on
were actually commands but they were
just feelings in the body
so that liberated me a lot i learned
about rewards
i learned about all kinds of motivations
one of the other big one was a dip in
the habit
so there's a time with every habit that
we feel great you know everything's
going great and then at some point we
hit this dip
that feels like we can't do it and so we
want to give up
so our usual pattern when we get hit by
this it's like getting punched in the
face
is like okay that's enough i don't want
to do this anymore and so we get really
discouraged
and i learned that if you have a plan
for when you get punched in the face and
you practice with that the dip doesn't
have to be
the end of the story it's just a part of
it is the practicing
just a rehearsal of sorts or
anticipation that the dip will come or
is there
another way to prepare yourself for that
punch in the face
is it knowing that it happens roughly x
period of time after you start
how have you done that successfully well
knowing that it's going to happen is a
big one
and then preparing for it because
usually what happens is we think it's
not going to happen
this time is going to be different and
then when it happens we're like uh
crap like it happened and so like that
must mean there's something wrong with
me
and so knowing that it's going to happen
that it's just a part of the process is
a really big one because it allows you
to be mentally
in the place where you can embrace this
and then the other part
of it is practicing what you're going to
do beforehand so if you
know it's going to happen and you know
how it's going to feel because
it's happened a number of times before
you can say oh
i'm in it and then you have a plan and
you mentally rehearse this beforehand
and you can practice with it in smaller
versions so i highly recommend
practicing anytime you get like a micro
discouragement
is practicing with that so giving
yourself some compassion
having some kind of a way to pull
yourself out of that state and so for me
just having someone to talk to was a big
one you know i'm screwing this up i
can't do this
having someone else to encourage me and
then i eventually learn to encourage
myself so there's lots of different
things we can do to
encourage ourselves and then just
learning to like
write it out was part of it because it
just it'll go it'll pass
and then another thing that i learned
this is not right away but i learned it
multiple habits into it is actually that
period is one of the deepest periods of
learning that we can have and so if we
can learn to
see it in that light where oh i can
learn a lot about myself
in this period it doesn't have to be a
negative thing when the dip
happens it's like oh this is actually
when i learn
what i'm all about this is how i learn
what the negative
thought patterns are that happen for me
are
and how to deal with those so it's
actually a really rich
area and most of us don't want to be in
it but if we learn that
oh this is where the growth really
happens then it doesn't have to be
anything that we need to get out of
right away there were i'm going to ask
you about
your physical movement not in the
running sense but actually the
relocation
sense you've had a number of moves and i
want to
talk about how those choices were made
before we get there just a couple of
things that came to mind as you were
expanding on on everything you just
mentioned the first is that the dip
happens in so many areas it happens
in physical training often in the
plateau of some type
it happens in skill acquisition with say
language learning
very predictably there will be a period
where you try to take on more complex
grammar and you take steps backwards
that feel
like you're failing if you aren't
anticipating that
as something predictable and
the embracing i can't remember the
athlete who said this to me but
embracing the suck
is concerned jim detmer who's a previous
podcast guest
and very wise practical guy has put it
to me that
when you have those moments and i'm not
by any stretch of the imagination
always excellent at seeing things this
way when
i'm in the midst of it but you view this
as a
pop quiz from the universe like the
universe says like oh yeah
you've been training and doing all these
things mindfulness meditation breathing
practice
four stressful moments like here's your
[ __ ] stressful moment yeah
let's see how you handle it hot shot
like you've been doing all this
supposed practice in the safe confines
of your living room
let's see how you operate in the real
world and that has been
a helpful not always a miraculous
reframe but uh certainly helpful so if
we talk about
or if we look at you're moving you left
guam
at one point and then you've moved a
number of times since could you speak
to why you and your family
left guam and what has driven
your decisions to move because a lot of
people as we record this
this is late september 2020 are moving
there are many people choosing to move
for many different reasons
and i would just love to know
more about what the insights and drivers
were for you
we moved in 2010 from guam to san
francisco
and that time we were a family of six
kids so
family of eight and we were in a really
comfortable place in guam we had so much
family around us a huge network
and i knew that we could just go on that
way and be fine but i also knew that
it was comfortable and the kids were
going to be trained in
comfort and that they would then get
stuck in that because that's what had
happened for me
so i wanted us to move out of our
comfort zone into a new place
and experience that together where i
could help them with that
mind shift and see the world and be able
to like
basically have access to the world and
then have choice they could go back to
guam where
we love guam or they could pretty much
move anywhere in the world
it was a hard thing because first of all
it's just heart-wrenching to say goodbye
to so many people that we love
we sold everything we moved with like a
backpack each
to san francisco knew almost no one
there
i met you there that was pretty great we
basically were in a place where
it was just completely foreign to us the
kids had never seen a homeless person
before
or anyone using drugs they got quite
used to that over the years we were
there
and so actually it was really hard
because they didn't want to be there
and i felt like i was maybe making a
mistake so it
taught me a lot about how i questioned
myself in those hard moments
but i really taught them a lot about
their
first reaction you know not liking it is
not always right
because they look back on it and say oh
i'm so glad
that you made that choice but i didn't
want to do it i was really unhappy for a
while
and so that really taught them a lot
about how we react to these kinds of
things
let's talk about the family a little bit
more and that move to san francisco
yeah to a lot of folks listening they're
going to think to themselves
holy smokes six kids and
how many just as a bit of backstory how
many
of those kids were homeschooled
oh yeah so well we're a blended uh brady
bunch family just to make that clear so
i have two for my ex-wife
my wife has two from her previous
marriage and then we
um came together and had two more so we
have three boys and three girls
and it's a very blended family so my two
for my ex-wife
went to regular school and then the
other four were all
all homeschooled in fact we do a version
of it as you know
called unschooling we still have two
teenagers in the house now who are being
unschooled and then we have two
adults who went through the unschooling
process
who are you know basically doing the
same thing but as adults
all right we're we're gonna we're gonna
dig into that i wanna talk about
unschooling before we get to that just
so i don't lose my train of thought
when you move to san francisco at the
time presumably
you and your wife discussed this
decisions were made
at the time the kids did not feel like
this was
perhaps the right decision how do you
think about making decisions for the
betterment of the family
even when or perhaps especially when
not everyone is in agreement
when you may face that type of blowback
or resistance how did you think about it
or how do you think about it
we went through a process so doing
anything like this with
other people you can't just make a
unilateral decision so we went through a
process with
them back when we were in guam and we we
had a whole discussion about the reasons
why
and i think they really were only like
50 convinced
but they agreed to it so that was kind
of the idea was
we asked them to agree to like this kind
of adventure
mindset to try something new to explore
things they didn't know
and i think they were hesitant but they
agreed to it
a piece of me knew that they were
resisting this and so part of it is just
kind of
talking about the adventure and the
excitement and all these new things that
we'd be able to explore together
and so they're like okay well maybe i
can do this discomfort stuff
if there is a good reason for it so
there was that
but also part of me knew that i had to
guide them
to being able to deal with all of the
negative stuff because that everything
comes with a cost and so they were gonna
be heartbroken to say goodbye to people
and
i knew that was actually a good thing
for them is to learn how to deal with
that even though it was painful
and really it's the same process as you
talked about what how i think about this
it's the same process that i think about
for myself when i make these decisions
it's like i know i'm going to go through
discomfort there's a part of me the
little kid in me that doesn't want to
do the hard stuff that wants to just be
in comfort
and there's a an adult part of me that
has to guide the little boy leo that
doesn't want to do it
and so that adult has to kind of give
compassion
and reassurance but also that's the part
that needs to make the decisions
when i'm in the like little boy leo
state of mind
i don't let myself make decisions at
that place because i know that that
one wants to hide or run and when my
kids are in that state of mind
too i usually don't let us make a
decision at that place we work through
that and then when they get to a place
where they're not
wanting to shut down that's when we make
a group decision
so that's the same exact process for
myself
we're going to come back to unschooling
but i think that a lot of people
present company included would be very
interested
to look at the early years
of zen habits because it seems like when
did zen habits
start when was the site launched january
2007
okay january 2007 in some respects
people must remember that 2007 to 2009
was was a golden era of blogging it's
very competitive
very similar to podcasting now in some
respects vlogs are still
very very powerful but hugely
competitive
many many entrants so to speak new blogs
options for readers but it seems like in
a
relatively short period of time let's
just say
18 to 24 months that zen habits had
really become
in the eyes of many a behemoth a a real
force to be reckoned with
how did that happen what can you point
to if any
decisions or particular posts or
anything at all
that helped to put zen habits on the map
yeah it really did happen in a matter of
months and part of me that wants to just
say like
i stumbled upon something just out of
pure luck and then another part
is that well no you worked your ass off
leo so
give yourself some credit yeah so i
started it really
just to block about a lot of the things
i've been learning
and changes that i was making and so it
really started
partly as accountability i got some
early responses from some readers
there was only a handful in the
beginning that really encouraged me
and it got me excited and i remember
maybe two and a half months into it
a point where i i said oh my god like i
really want to do this all the time
and i had a day job at the time what was
your day job if i
may ask yeah i was working for the
government in guam
at the time i think it was the guam
legislature i was
helping with veterans from the
legislature so it didn't take up all my
attention let's just say that
it was the kind of job where a lot of
people will play like solitaire
for like a quarter of the day and i
realized like i didn't want to do that
and so i just used all of my spare time
even when i was like
supposed to be doing other work just
doing blogging
a switch just flipped where i was so
passionate about it
and i realized like oh this could be my
calling and so
i had never had that before this idea
that something could be my calling it
was always kind of like just do
something for the paycheck
and when i had that switch flipped i
went on this
crazy like hyperdrive where like
i was writing a post every day for zen
habits
i also started freelancing for other
blogs where i was
writing one post a week for them so for
five different ones
so it was five posts a week for those
paid blogs
and then i would do guest posts for
other blogs and i was doing about five
of those a week
and so it was like 15 to 20 blog posts a
week
how did you choose the five outlets or
blog
post options how did you select those
well i was already uh doing freelance
writing for magazines and guam
and so i decided instead of writing for
those which i wasn't
inspired to write for i'd write for the
online ones even if the pay was less
so i looked for blogs strategically that
first of all they were
paying people freelancers and second
their audience had some kind of overlap
with mine
so they you know there was productivity
there was
mostly self-improvement type stuff so
similar audiences
and the effect that i had and i kind of
realized this early on when i started
making this switch
the effect was that if you're reading
about self-improvement
there was a good chance that i would you
would come across me
because all of these self-improvement
blogs that were paying me
i was there every week and then a bunch
of other blogs that were doing
self-improvement
would allow me to be a guest poster and
so if you're reading this blog about
self-improvement
you probably came across leo of zen
habits if you were
within this certain kind of sphere it
was almost like i was everywhere
and that was kind of crazy that i could
do that at the time
but yeah i actually had people write to
me and say man you are just like
on every blog that i read and of course
i wasn't on every blog
in the world but for this particular
type of person that i was trying to
reach
i was on almost every blog that they
were reading
just a quick thanks to one of our
sponsors and we'll be right back to the
show this episode is brought to you by
athletic greens i get asked all the time
what i would take if i could only take
one supplement the answer is invariably
athletic greens
i view it as all-in-one nutritional
insurance i recommended it in fact in
the four hour body this is more than 10
years ago
and i did not get paid to do so with
approximately 75 vitamins
minerals and whole foods sourced
ingredients you'd be very hard-pressed
to find a more nutrient-dense and
comprehensive formula on the market it
has multivitamins
multi-mineral greens complex probiotics
and prebiotics for gut health and
immunity formula digestive enzymes
adaptogens and much more i usually take
it
once or twice a day just to make sure
i've covered my bases
if i miss anything i'm not aware of of
course i focus on nutrient-dense meals
to begin with that's the basis
but athletic greens makes it easy to get
a lot of nutrition when whole foods
aren't readily available
from travel packets i always have them
in my bag
when i'm zipping around right now
athletic greens is giving my audience a
special offer on top of their all-in-one
formula
which is a free vitamin d supplement and
five
free travel packs with your first
subscription purchase many of us are
deficient in vitamin d
i found that true for myself which is
usually produced in our bodies from sun
exposure so
adding a vitamin d supplement to your
daily routine is a great option for
additional immune support support your
immunity
gut health and energy by visiting
athleticgreens.com
tim you'll receive up to a year's supply
of vitamin d
and five free travel packs with your
subscription again that's
athleticgreens.com
tim
now i'm trying to step into my mental
time machine and go back to say 2007 to
2009.
i want to say that at the time there
would have been
some powerhouses to reckon with in the
productivity space
life hacker 40 holders
were there any particular outlets that
looking back and doing a sort of 80 20
analysis of sorts
that really seem to help you reach
critical mass for any number of reasons
it's hard to remember
i remember the first time that i got
linked to from a bigger blog it was a
blog called dumb little man
i think they're still around but they
had so many more readers and i had like
you know 20 or something like that and
somehow they had read my blog and linked
to it
and i remember looking at the stats and
it just spiked up into the thousands
and it was just like this mind-blowing
thing which
they linked to or what was it it was
like 20
productivity hacks or something like
that i definitely wrote a lot of link
bait
type headlines at the time i tried to
put real wisdom
real like useful stuff in there but i
played around with a bunch of
types of titles for the post that were
attention grabbing and eventually i
moved away from that because it just
didn't feel
very good but definitely was doing a lot
of it at the time just experimenting
i wanted to just basically try anything
because i didn't know it would work or
not so i tried everything
that was the kind of like i said
hyperdrive that i went into
is i basically tried every single thing
because i didn't know what worked and
then by the end of 2007
i figured out the things that worked and
the ones that didn't and so i
stopped doing the ones that didn't feel
in alignment with me and then
really just focused on the important
stuff i think that's the case when we
try anything that we don't know how to
do it we try like
everything possible and then we narrow
it down to what actually does matter
by the way i want to say that 2007
when zen habits took off is when i met
you online we never met in person
that year but you had come out with four
hour work week which was just this
powerhouse of a book and you were
starting out with your blog as well
and i was also coming out with a book
which i didn't know how to do and you
were
coming out with a blog which you were
new to and so we kind of crossed paths
at that point where i was good at
blogging and not good at books you were
good at books and not good at blogging
and eventually you got really good at
blogging like your blog just took off
and so it's just really cool to see you
rise up in that space just because
i think anything you set your mind to
you're going to be really good at i
appreciate you saying that man it was
it was really fun to have those early
interactions and just like you
in the very beginning i did
a lot of experimentation with all sorts
of clickbaity
titles and headlines and blog rolls of
various types and i
i really threw as much as i could
against the wall
and it's very true that you have to
throw a lot against the wall
to know what works but i would add to
that you need to throw
a lot against the wall to determine what
works for
you because if you're experimenting in a
new medium you really don't know
what you're going to enjoy and you don't
know what you'll be
good at and i think those are very
closely related in the sense
that your power zone tends to be some
degree of inherent skill
or predilection towards a certain format
that's true with podcasting too
that predilection or enjoyment then
gives you the stamina to outlast
and compete so i think that both of
those
are extremely important ingredients and
if i think back to one of the inflection
points for instance for my blog
it's very clearly getting on the front
page of digg
digg for the first time with
my geek to freak post which is about
building muscle i remember that one
controversial post and the amount of
traffic
that that brought was just un
imaginable right were there other
particular posts of yours
that you recall or projects
right zen mind is one that i'm wondering
if that kind of
grabbed people in a way or if that type
of writing
grabbed people in a way that brought you
dedicated readers is there anything at
all that comes to mind as
having done a lot of heavy lifting yeah
and by the way
dig was a big one for me too i got in
the front page of dig a bunch of times
and that
those were like the early days of social
media reddit was also getting big and
there was
a bookmarking site called delicious or
if you got on their front page
you'd also get a bunch of traffic so i
remember
you're like bringing back all these
early memories the ones that really
worked for me were around productivity
and motivation habit change and then the
other
one that was a big surprise to me
actually i didn't think anyone would be
interested in it was simplicity
and that's when i said that luck was a
big factor
because there were a lot of productivity
and motivation
blogs at the time there weren't that
many that blogged about habits at the
time but there were a lot around
productivity and motivation
so mine wouldn't have stood out if it
were just about that
but i brought an element to everything
that i wrote about
of simplicity so my blog was a lot about
simplifying your life but
i realized like oh it doesn't have to be
just about
simplifying your possessions i could
write about simple productivity
and simple motivation and so i brought
simplicity that lens
to almost everything that i wrote about
and that
turned out to be a distinguisher for me
that i just kind of looked
upon but again you throw everything
against the wall so simplicity was
something that i thought i was only
interested in and not a lot of other
people were
so i wrote about it because i liked it
but i thought that wasn't going to
resonate i had to write about
productivity and motivation
and it turns out that i tapped into a
nerve that people
really crave simplicity in their lives
when they're feeling overwhelmed
and chaotic and just overloaded with all
the stuff
with all the emails and messages and
everything that we have
simplicity struck a nerve that i wasn't
expecting to strike
that was the one surprise for me that
year of many surprises that was the
biggest one
and i still feel really lucky that i
wrote about that and tapped into this
like
zeitgeist at the time how would you
suggest people
think about simplification i'm sure many
people listening
would like to simplify they listen to
your story of each family member with a
backpack
and they don't know how to go from zero
to sixty so to speak
and given that you have so much practice
applying simplicity to different
areas if you were and i know you don't
necessarily do this
but if you're doing sort of maybe you do
you tell me but sort of one-on-one
high-end consulting and someone said i
want to buy my life
what would you say to them or do with
them by the way i do
do one-on-one coaching i didn't do that
until a couple years ago but now i do
the place to start is how things got not
simple in the first place
because you can get rid of like 90 of
your stuff
and simplify your day and then i'll be
done with you as a consultant and
consider that a huge success and then i
come back in three months and things are
back to
their complicated things so like how did
we get here in the first place i think
is really important to look at
and the reason why we have so much stuff
and we've
have so much debt and we take on so much
in our lives
is really because of uncertainty and
anxiety
you notice this year as we record this
we're in the middle of a pandemic is
the most anxiety that people have felt
in a long time
probably since like war times and the
great depression
and so as that has gone up people
started ordering things online more
one of the things that people started to
reach for and so like we got so many
amazon packages because we couldn't go
anywhere
and release that anxiety and so that was
a way for people to release that
and so that's always been true is that
we always have
gone to getting more stuff as a way to
feel
control in our lives or security or like
i've
some kind of protection against the
chaos of this world
and so i think that's the place to look
is like how did you get there what are
the mindset and the thought processes
that trigger you
to having so much in your life and this
also applies to
having too many commitments and too many
goals and projects and
meetings and things like that how do we
fill our lives up so much
and then we can start to look at that
underlying stuff and dealing
with the uncertainty and anxiety because
the external stuff is only symptoms and
i'm not someone who just likes to treat
symptoms
but the symptoms are fun to treat too
it's just you can't just do that
got it let's look at the commitments
and non-physical
forms of clutter because i at least
selfishly for myself
feel pretty good about possessions and
material
accumulation but the
commitments and projects are perhaps
unexpectedly to some listening are an
area where at least as a stress
response in times of acute stress
i will often over commit myself i think
as a way to
not feel whatever is coming to the
surface
what would your prescription be to
someone who wants to
become better at saying no
or simply someone who wants to reverse
the trend of over committing
i love that you're bringing this up
because it really strikes to the
the core of of what i've been digging
into in the last few years which is
uncertainty and anxiety but in terms of
over
commitment i would say it's really good
actually to make
an external commitment that i want to
only have this much in my life
that's really the place to start so we
don't necessarily have to start
underneath
we start externally i know i just i'm
contradicting what i just said
but it really helps to see the stuff
underlying if you say okay
i commit to only doing one project at a
time or
three projects at a time or i commit to
taking completely
saturdays sundays off and friday
afternoons
you know something like that where you
commit to something externally which is
a limitation
and then what happens is you see
yourself rebelling against that when
things feel really uncertain
it's the urge to undo that commitment
that we start to work with
so the underlying part of it is like oh
i'm feeling a lot of anxiety
we actually don't usually notice when
we're feeling anxiety we just start to
go automatically to our ways of reacting
to that anxiety which like you said
i think a lot of people listening can
probably relate to what you just said
which is
we go and take on a bunch of stuff we go
and do a bunch of things
or for other people it would be like
netflix or youtube
so comfort things is one common response
procrastinating on a lot of things is
another common one
but for people like me and you who are
doers we go out and do a bunch of things
and that's our way of feeling more in
control
when things are feeling out of control
so if you have a commitment
externally to only do a certain number
of things and you notice like oh i've
broken that commitment in the last week
then you can start to see like oh
there's something under that
that is coming up there's anxiety here
and that that allows you to bring
awareness to the anxiety
and then to start to work with that in a
way that doesn't break the commitment
and so if you have that kind of external
thing that holds you in that commitment
and i really like having accountability
so like you commit to
a group of close friends that you're
only going to do
a certain number of projects that kind
of thing or have a certain number of
meetings or
my meetings are only going to be on
tuesdays and thursdays or something like
that
then it really helps you to like
highlight all the times when you're
trying to rebel against that
what are some of the rules constraints
forms of accountability that you have
found
powerful in your own life i've tried
like as you can imagine i've tried
everything
and it changes over time as some of them
get easy after a while and so i take on
something else to
adjust to the level that i'm at right
now so like right now
i realized that i was filling up almost
every single day seven days a week with
zoom calls
first it was like there was only going
to be on certain days and then
it started to fill up every other time
so i started first of all
having weekends off no calls on weekends
which meant i had to move
things away from that and then i started
doing no calls on friday so i could
still work
on fridays but no calls and then i
started taking i decided i was going to
take decembers and june's
off of coaching people and then also
doing meetings
each step along the way i had to make
some shifts and then i
had to watch myself rebel against that
which i have actually recently started
filling up fridays
even though i'm like oh it's just this
one time so if i'm gonna
get to do a podcast with tim ferriss oh
that's okay right
because that's a big deal but nothing
else and then once you start to do that
you start to see
yourself doing it a bunch of other times
after you've let you kind of open up the
floodgates
i know i'm the snake in the tree you got
to be careful yeah
tim's an enabler
i'd love to talk a bit or hear rather a
bit
about zen buddhism so zen buddhism for
a lot of people i think is more than
anything
unclear and confusing and
you have recommended in for instance in
my last book tribe mentors
recommended a few books related to zen
buddhism zen mind beginner mind
by shooting suzuki and also what is zen
subtitle plane talk for a beginner's
mind by norman fisher
f-i-s-c-h-e-r are you still
finding zen buddhism to be helpful in
your life and if so
why how would you describe it and its
impact
in your life it's such an interesting
topic because in some ways if you start
to dive into it it does become really
confusing
and i actually don't recommend zen mine
beginner's mind as the first book
it is a great book it's got so much
wisdom in it but when you start to read
it it doesn't make a lot of sense
so if you read one book to start with
that what is zen by norman fisher is a
great intro
but also if you don't dive into it and
you just have this like
idea of what zen is people think of it
as like calm and tranquility
and simplicity and in some ways it is it
does work with that kind of stuff
so when i started i had that idea like
oh it's going to be just mindfulness and
simplicity
and calm and then i started diving into
it and i had that same
response which is like i don't
understand what this is about at all
i don't know what they're talking about
and if you go to like a zen temple and
like
meditate with them there's a bunch of
chanting and it feels really off-putting
and confusing so i completely
acknowledge there's a lot of
confusion that comes up around it and
it's just because it's like this old
tradition
where they have their ways of doing
things i do find it really useful
i'm i study with a zen teacher and i am
studying
the precepts which are you know like you
know don't intoxicate yourself and
don't abuse sex and that kind of stuff
so i study with these precepts as a way
to deepen into the practice
and i'm planning to take some vows in
the
near future so it's something that i am
diving deeper into
and the reason why i find it so helpful
is not because i need to be like
some like zen monk some zen master or
anything like that
but because it is a way of
practice that allows you to open up in
the middle
of the most difficult stuff that you
could face the dip that we talked about
earlier the uncertainty and
anxiety that we talked about that's
coming up this year and allows you just
to be
completely open in the middle of that
it's that embracing the suck
that you talked about it's even like
realizing the suck doesn't even suck
it's actually just
life it allows you to open up in the
middle of life
some of the hardest stuff and be
completely open
and relaxed and present with it and it's
just a completely different way of being
than what we're usually taught
and it's not something that you can just
do in a week you have to actually
practice with it for a long time
practice can be discouraging it can be
something that we
shy away from because we're busy and
then when you notice yourself
discouraged that's when you bring the
practice to that
that's how i've been practicing with it
lately you mentioned the precepts the
bodhisattva
precepts that's right are you open to
sharing what
vows you are considering taking you
brought the word bodhisattva so the
bodhisattva
vow in general is just i know you're
familiar with it but for those who
aren't
it's this idea that you're going to help
all beings
which is like this impossible about it's
like how the hell are you gonna help
every single being on earth right which
is actually one of the amazing things is
that you turn
towards this thing that feels completely
impossible
and you ask yourself the question
bringing curiosity to it
what would it be like to turn your heart
open
to helping all beings to this intention
this really wholesome
heartfelt intention to help people who
are suffering
in the world and so that's what the
bodhisattva vow
is and it's about to basically uphold
these 16 bodhisattva
precepts which i have not memorized if
you quiz me right now
if you give me the pop quiz i won't be
able to list them off but they're all
actually really the same vowel which is
this thing to open up beyond our
self-concern
which is where most of us are almost all
the time
is we're in self-concern and like what
does this person think of me will i be
judged am i going to fail should i take
on more
all of these things are all about
ourselves and there's nothing
wrong with that that's not a bad thing
but the bodhisattva
vow is about opening beyond that to
all beings and it's this amazing
way of being that you like are no longer
only in self-concern you still
care about yourself but that's not the
thing that limits you and that's not
where your mind is at and where your
heart's coming from
it really actually is the most powerful
thing it's it's almost like what i
talked about when i talked about
quitting smoking is having some reason
to do it other than yourself
when i made the vow to my daughter and
my wife it actually held me
in the darkest parts when i didn't want
to do it when i was faced with
discomfort or punched in the face
like you if you have something that
matters more than yourself
you can actually go through the hardest
discomfort
and the same thing when i hit a marathon
like at the point when i hit the wall in
the marathon
why was i doing this i had to have a
reason other than my own comfort because
i was not feeling comfortable at the
time and so i had to have a reason to do
it that was more important to me than my
own comfort
and that's what the bodhisattva vow is
what was it in the case of the marathon
for you
it was my kids honestly if you're going
to ask me like a number of
all my different motivations 90 of the
time it's my kids
but nowadays it's not just them but at
that time
that was the most accessible thing for
me that was beyond myself was my wife
and kids
it was so easy like looking at their
faces to really care
about them and their hearts and like
being an inspiration to them
and just to show you like how that
actually did pay off
a few years later they did a birthday
party for me where
they celebrated me as like a superhero
they like had
super dad and like this is how they saw
me was this person who was larger than
life
and willing to be a hero it was so
touching because that was what i wanted
for them was to have this
example who wasn't stuck in comfort zone
who could go out of that for something
that was more meaningful
that's what it wasn't for me um when it
came to the marathon was
i'm doing this to show them that this
could be done
i'm looking at the bodhisattva precepts
on wikipedia
and of course you can go as deep as you
want on this but just to give people a
flavor and i want you to correct me if
this doesn't sound familiar but i'm
looking at the
brahmajala sutra which has a list of 10
major and
48 minor bodies so
something for everybody and what strikes
me at least
about these is there's some similarity
to say the ten commandments right
there's in the ten commandments case
thou shalt not kill
right but here's an addition to that and
of course these are all translations but
not to kill or encourage others to kill
and at the end of each of these there is
or encourage
others to x right to use false words in
speech or encourage others to do so
not to broadcast the misdeeds or faults
of the buddhist assembly
nor encourage others to do so not to
harbor anger or encourage
others to be angry and so on and so
forth it
is as you mentioned broader than
just the sort of skin encapsulated ego
that we refer to as i
by the wording at least that i'm seeing
here in the precepts
if we harken back to family and the
family your kids
being such a form of
drive and motivation and accountability
i want to
ensure that i don't miss unschooling
okay could you
speak to how on god's green earth
you you had so many kids homeschooled
and is it you and your wife
doing the homeschooling do you have help
i think for a lot of people who have
kids right now they have seen in some
cases how
woefully under-prepared they are
to assist with schooling at home
and there are certainly technical
hurdles right but this is something
that has been forced upon
by circumstance and sort of force mature
through pandemic
quarantine and so on millions of people
who have been completely unprepared
so i would love to hear from you what
unschooling
looked like can i speak i do want to
dive into that but i want to speak
just briefly to something that you
talked about in the previous section
which was the
bodhisattva vows because you compare
them to the 10 commandments and there's
a big difference that i want to just
touch on
they aren't rules or commandments so
much as ways to kind of examine
how you're practicing with this stuff so
like you know thou shall not kill
there's a similar precept to that and
encouraging others as you said
but the difference is it's only a a lens
to examine
how are you practicing with the main
intention of all of this stuff
and it's not about making yourself wrong
and judging ourselves which is
kind of where we usually come from in
our western society is like ways
all kinds of ways to judge ourselves and
so that's that's something i just wanted
to bring out is
it's really just oh maybe i haven't
killed anybody but have i done anything
that is aggressive towards people
and so looking at that and there's
always deeper ways and there's even
much deeper ways to go into these things
so i just wanted to kind of share that
this
is they're really only just practice
tools for this
this area okay unschooling which is an
amazing topic
but i have to start by saying if you ask
how on
god's green earth my secret ingredient
of course is and not so secret is my
wife so she
decided to quit her job as a teacher so
she had some background in education
and then homeschool our kids and at the
time we just did
homeschooling which is like school in
the house so we had the same kind of
classes
same kind of lessons and books and
everything and so that's and to this day
like she's down there right now doing
that with them
so i i definitely i'm a big part of
their unschooling
but i just have to say like we're
actually really lucky that she gets to
do that as a full-time thing how was the
decision made i don't want to skip over
that
sure why did that happen well we were
inspired by my sister who was
homeschooling her kids her two kids that
was one thing and then the other one was
we realized for some of our kids who
were in school
school was not working out for them well
we had one son who
very intelligent but he didn't conform
well to the the rules of school
and what we realized as we started to
look into this stuff is that school
in a lot of ways is very much about
conformity
and follow the rules and you'll you'll
get along fine
and it doesn't matter so much about you
know how much you've learned but
more how especially in the early days of
school like how much you can actually
follow the rules
and so he was learning a lot but he was
not following the rules and so like one
day
he was he had read whatever was supposed
to be read in the in the class
and was bored and so he started he broke
out a novel
that he was reading and started reading
it and he got sent to the principal's
office because of that
and that was like our wake-up call it's
like oh they don't
care that much about him learning it's
more about him following the rules
and so that was one it was following the
rules
versus learning and so we started to
look at like is this possible for her to
quit
that was why we made the decision but
another
thing that we learned along the way that
i think is really important
this day and age is that unschooling
so we went away from the structure of
schooling
to the structure of homeschooling and
then we tossed all of that out
in favor of unschooling which is a way
of learning that's completely
unstructured
other than what the kid wants to
structure for themselves
and so the idea behind unschooling is
that you're learning in the same way
that you and i do today tim as adults
like you and i have not stopped just
because we're out of school
we haven't stopped learning we're
actually probably learning more than we
did when we were in school
but we're learning on our own terms
because we are motivated by it
at our own pace with our own structure
that's what unschooling is
is empowering the kids to actually
decide for themselves
what they care about what they want to
learn and what that means is that
they're not going to necessarily learn
everything that everyone is
quote unquote supposed to learn by the
age of 13
but they would have learned a whole
different set of things and the
really important thing is that actually
learning can be
incredibly fun that they learned how to
face uncertainty they learned how to
motivate themselves
and create their own structure they
learned that it's okay to give up on
learning something
if you found something else that you're
more passionate about
they also learn how to hold themselves
into learning something when they
are feeling discouraged about it so
there's like a whole set
of meta learning that is available to
unschoolers that
isn't given to regular schoolers and i
wanted to say like
you're not making a bad decision if
you're sending your kids to school
and you're not a bad person if you're a
teacher or a bad parent
so i don't judge anybody who does that
but school
by its nature is someone making the
decisions for the kids so they it takes
away all of the decision making for them
it takes away the uncertainty of their
learning path because
someone else has laid it out for you so
you feel like okay this is laid out for
me so i'm just going to follow it
and then you get to college and the same
thing is there's a path laid out for you
and then you get out of college and then
you're like now what do i do
because there's no path laid out for you
as an adult
and so what happens to most people is
that they get out of the schooling thing
and they look for another thing to
replace that
how can i go to a place where someone
else has made the decisions for me
and i can have the certainty of
following someone else's path
that they've laid out and as you know as
an entrepreneur
the most rich kind of learning areas are
where someone has not laid the path out
for you and you have to make these
decisions for yourself
and you constantly question whether
you're doing it right
and that's what unschooling is really in
a nutshell do you feel
in that case that you are preparing them
for entrepreneurship
predominantly because i would imagine i
want to hear you
speak to this just because i'm
speculating but that
in the process of unschooling your kids
you are providing them with a lot of
adaptability but
probably handicapping their ability to
travel a more traditional path
afterwards to say colleges
is that is that not the case i would
just love to hear how you think about
some of the trade-offs well first of all
it is i don't know if it's handicapping
them they definitely
it is a little bit harder to get into
college but there's plenty of
homeschoolers and unschoolers who get
into college there's definitely a path
my kids so far have not chosen that the
ones who were unschooled
but it's definitely a path and it's not
that difficult it's just
you have to put a little bit of extra
effort because it's not all laid out for
you
so i would say that's one thing just to
make sure that's clear there's actually
books written on how to get into college
as a
as an unschooler but the entrepreneur
thing i do want to speak to that
because my favorite person to talk to
this about is people like you
who are entrepreneurs or creative types
authors you know
anyone who's done anything that deals
with uncertainty
and discomfort and knows what that's
like any kind of leader anyone running a
nonprofit
those people get it so as i start to
talk about like oh
having to figure out your own path the
people who have had to do that for
themselves
they instinctively get it they already
know what that's like
and then if they have a kid or they're
about to have a kid but their kids
aren't in school yet they haven't made
that decision yet
that's the perfect time that's like the
golden zone to reach someone
if they're an entrepreneur or a creative
type or leader of some kind
and they have a kid or about two who's
not in school yet
it's absolutely uh preparation for any
kind of
uncharted territory if you're going to
be an entrepreneur
if you're going to be any kind of leader
in any kind of organization
where you're not being told what to do
but you have to figure stuff out and
deal with the uncertainty
of that the self-doubt unschooling is
like incredible
preparation for that and is constantly
filled with
uncertainty self-doubt people judging
you
and not getting you which is exactly the
path of an entrepreneur
and yeah constantly having to deal with
all of that stuff
and discouragement motivation structure
all of the exact same stuff that you and
i deal with on a daily basis
that's what an unschooler starts to do
from day one
and they're not going to be good at it
at first and so it's great to have
someone who's there to guide them
but they get trained in it by the time
they get to be 18
they can definitely figure out their
path to college there but they can also
realize like actually i don't need
college for most professions right i
don't need
unless i'm going to be like a doctor or
a lawyer or something like that
i can actually do without college so
there's the uncollege
kind of route as well are there any
resources that you would recommend
for people who would like to learn more
about homeschooling and unschooling
and common pitfalls best practices
yeah there's a bunch of books i'm
totally out of date to be honest
uh so there's some radical stuff
about just completely like liberating
there's one called teenage liberation
handbook
which i highly recommend there's an
author named alfie
cohn k-o-h-n something like that he's
actually
also pretty radical i would actually
lean towards anything that talks about
unschooling rather than homeschooling
it's a
important distinction unschooling is a
subset of homeschooling so
it is at home but it's really about
all the stuff that i talked about
choosing your own path and dealing with
that
i wouldn't recommend any book that's
focused on homeschooling itself because
they're usually about how to do
school in the home let's talk more about
charting the unknown all right and
this is unknown to me maybe known to you
but
i am looking at a quote from a fast
company piece that you wrote in 2015
about the constant tension and struggle
between contentment and self-improvement
and here's the paragraph for the last
eight years i've had an internal
struggle between wanting to improve
myself and wanting to be content to be
honest i haven't completely figured
out how to resolve that struggle but i'm
working on it what is the root of this
struggle well when i started zen habits
more than eight years ago i'd been
working for more than a year on changing
all my habits with lots of success all
of those changes were rooted in my
dissatisfaction with myself
i'd had a lot of success but the
dissatisfaction never went away
so this is dated of course it's five
years ago or even a bit more and i'd
just
love to hear from you as i've
also observed your writing shift from
productivity
which we could in some sense pair with
self-improvement
to tossing out productivity and thinking
about simplicity and
many other subjects are there any
particular
changes in your
life habits new beliefs anything
that has had the greatest impact on your
contentment
or a large impact on your contentment i
think the thing that
i did is i kept digging deeper like i
was never
content to use that word um with just
like the surface level stuff which is
where i started
um and there's nothing wrong with that
stuff the productivity and all the
systems and
all that kind of stuff i think is
amazing and
there's always deeper levels and so for
me it's like oh what why am i not
content
i got my life under control i got my
debt under control habits and everything
like that
but there's still something that i'm not
satisfied with
and so i started to dig into that and i
think what i
hit upon was this underlying uncertainty
about myself
am i good enough is kind of the question
that feeling of inadequacy that a lot of
us will feel
and there's nothing wrong with that
feeling i think that's something that
kind of gets bred into us by our society
this just becomes part of our world like
i'm not enough and the world is
constantly giving us messages of that
and we give ourselves that message so i
learned to like kind of sit with that
that feeling and i realized it was just
a feeling it wasn't actually the end of
the world
and then i learned to like tap into
self-compassion and i think that was a
huge one for me
was learning to be compassionate for
myself what if i may pause you just for
a second yeah
what did that look like in practice
yeah that was a hard one for me because
at first it was more of a mental
intellectual exercise i just kind of let
myself
off the hook i'm not such a bad person
and just reassuring talk
it actually became when i started
practicing more not only with meditation
but with
heart-centered meditations like meta i'm
sure you're familiar with that one
loving kindness meditation and so i
started practicing with that and that
one is
for those unfamiliar with it is
basically
this thing where you kind of picture
someone else or a group of people
and you start to wish an end to their
suffering for example or
wish happiness upon them and it's just a
lovely
little meditation right so you start
thinking these thoughts like may they be
happy
and you think about your loved ones in
pain
and suffering and may they be happy
think about other people in the world
who are suffering
may they be happy it's just a really
beautiful meditation but what i learned
as i kept practicing with this was there
was a feeling in my heart that would be
generated
of loving kindness and that's really the
main point of that
is not so much like this thought process
of
loving kindness but a heart feeling
which is really hard to describe until
you start to practice it and then you
start to realize like oh yeah
that's the same thing that i feel
instantly when someone who i care about
is actually in pain i really want them
to
not be in pain right so this is like
human thing but you can actually conjure
it up
and so i learned to do that through this
meditation and
i start to notice when i am feeling
inadequate or like there's something
wrong with me or i'm not doing enough or
i got through my day
really busy but i never i still didn't
do enough there was
always this feeling of not being enough
that i had
and i started to give myself compassion
when i started to recognize that this
kind of loving kindness
compassion in my heart and so it was
just like almost like this pouring out
of this loving feeling towards myself
towards my own wounds
which sounds very kind of woo-woo and
like i think there's people who
won't resonate with that but actually it
was a really powerful thing when i
started to practice that for myself
because we don't do that we are not
trained in that as a society
and by practice would that
show up as you say being really hard on
yourself and before you go
into dinner with your family just taking
three minutes with your eyes closed to
do
a loving kindness self-talk meditation
or did it
look like something else i think of it
more like this
salve that i just put on a wound anytime
i'm feeling it act up you know
so i have like all these wounds from
like childhood and and so forth
and so yeah when i feel like oh i'm not
enough or there's something wrong with
me
or i'm just judging myself and kind of
stuck in one of those kinds of
thought patterns it really just feels
like a wound in my heart
and so like i just noticed that i'm like
oh i'm feeling some anxiety right now
can i give myself some compassion
oh i'm feeling really down about myself
and how much how little i've done this
week or how
addicted i've gotten to something and so
i'll just give myself compassion it's
really anytime anything difficult
is showing up frustration anxiety fear
self-doubts and anger things like that
so you know
you're feeling frustration with someone
you can point your finger at them and
really focus on them but you could also
notice
your feeling hurt and just give yourself
some compassion and that really helps
with that frustration
and you can't really be like
open-hearted and open-minded towards
this person who you're frustrated with
until you've given yourself some
compassion first and dealt with your own
pain
yeah that strikes that strikes me as
very true certainly with
a lot of my reactive behavior over the
last few decades and i want to also
recommend
for people who are interested in meta
metta
or loving meditation it really can have
a
very pronounced very fast effect on your
state
and one book that gave a great
description of this and there are many
but
it is joy on demand written by
meng tan so c-h-a-d-e hyphen
m-e-n-g last name t-a-n
who created a massively successful
course internal to google at the time
called search within yourself i believe
and the book contains some really
fantastic
descriptions and prescriptions for
loving kindness meditation so i just
wanted to
share that for people who might want to
yeah explore more there's
um another one just to mention another
resource because i i know your listeners
love
resources tara brock i think you're
familiar with her work
i am yeah radical acceptance that's what
it is she's awesome yeah
it's a great book yeah it's also one of
the key books in the quiver
which like a lot of things has a very
generic
kind of seemingly hand-wavy squishy
title
with a lot of very practical tactical
recommendations within i'm looking at
some of the notes in front of me
leo this is a might seem like a left
turn
but it's it's of interest to me because
we've been speaking
somewhat broadly i mean specifically
about your experience but
broadly in terms of say gender
experience right this is
everything we're talking about applies
to everyone at least to the extent that
i can tell
in 2018 you went through training with a
men's group
that deep into masculine practice
and seemed to relate to the sort of
masculine
and feminine polarity work of david data
and
you know here i'm just taking you know
john weinland can you
speak to why you did that training and
some of the things that you took away
from it why did i do it
i think there was a part of me that
would
collapse in the middle of discomfort so
like let's just say
an argument with my wife or pain from
like a family member
or something like that and so i would
collapse in the middle of that
not physically but like my heart would
close and i'd be so discouraged and
and just frustrated with them and so i
like was looking for
something to to work with that with and
i did a workshop with
john weinland who is a disciple of david
data but he's also branched out and done
his own work
and so i actually think he's like really
an incredible teacher
for this kind of stuff and we did some
practices there there were mindfulness
type practices that were quite
incredible and so i decided
to just dive deep with him and i went
into a nine-month program with john
and just to be clear the polarity work
here there's there's a
they talk about the energy of the
masculine and the feminine
and this is not necessarily gendered
every single person
in this framework has both masculine and
feminine energy in us
and so this is really about practicing
leadership
of our own emotions in order to be able
to provide leadership for
let's say our families or in our
relationship
so the leadership is the masculine where
you're providing structure and
consciousness
and able to be with all of our
pain and emotions and all the stuff that
comes up
which would be considered feminine all
of our emotions all change all
destructive and creative energy
is the feminine in all of us and so the
masculine in all of us is the
consciousness and structure and
stillness
and so learning to practice in this way
was a really profound thing for me
that allowed me to practice with my own
inner like wounded
self and my own emotions but then be
able to do that for my kids for my wife
for all my other loved ones and for my
readers and the
coaching clients that i work with and
the groups that i work with
so be able to hold space for them was
really important to do this practice
because the practice is not just knowing
it intellectually but it's actually
getting it in like your nervous system
so that you've trained in it
for a number of months and in fact it's
a lifetime practice
so that when someone shows up as a
coaching client for example who is
completely complaining about you instead
of complaining about them back you just
kind of hold space for them with
complete consciousness and love
and you don't need to collapse could you
give an example of one
framework or concept or concrete
practice
that you took from that training one of
the best ones
this is the most like i know people like
you and me love practical like tactical
stuff that comes from
deep stuff right so that one of the best
ones that i use tactically
on a daily basis it's part meditation
then part trying to make a decision so
let's say
i have a lot of things on my plate and i
have to decide okay what do i need to do
today
and i could really could be anything and
i'm feeling pulled in a lot of
directions
so i think a lot of people can relate to
that what i'll do is i'll drop
into it's like a little mini meditation
where my
consciousness goes like wide like almost
as like wide as the universe
right so like really open mind
and really deep consciousness so you go
into a state like that and it could
really
with practice it could really take two
seconds to get into that state
and then in that state and again i want
to give complete credit to john weinland
for these practices
in this state i drop in the question
what is life calling me to do
and you can interpret that in a lot of
different ways life god
your inner heart your intuition whatever
it is
but in that state of wide open
consciousness we're no longer in our
place of self-concern and what what
comes up for me is usually just one
thing
and it's really clear i'll i'll do that
at the beginning of a day
is just drop in that question what is
life calling me to do and it's just one
thing and then i'll just
do that and i might after that ask the
same question and just do that and one
after the other just ask that question
and it's usually the most important
thing it's not the most urgent
or the thing that i'm most afraid about
but it's actually just the most
important thing
have you had any answers pop up that
were
surprising or particularly unexpected
for you
yeah you don't get anything just
completely out of left field
yeah sometimes i think like oh it's this
fire that i need to put out
eat nachos now nothing like that no not
not yet i'm sure that will come up
actually i have had some where it's like
oh you need to take some rest
and i like thought i had to go and do a
bunch of things because i was feeling
very overwhelmed and i was like no you
need to rest so maybe the nachos would
have been a good
part of that but another one that
surprises me is
you need to go and apologize to somebody
like
someone came up in the middle of that
i'm like oh i hurt them and
unintentionally of course but
i did hurt them and i need to go and
make amends and so sometimes that comes
up and i'm like oh
shoot like i didn't even think of that
until i asked that question
well leo i want to
give readers plenty to chew on but not
too much to chew on
i think we've covered a lot of ground is
there anything else that you think we
should
explore on this conversation we've
touched a number of times on
uncertainty and anxiety and i want to
just leave people with something
here that i think is really important so
in this world right now that we're in
as again as we record this we're in the
middle of pandemic
and lockdowns and frustrations with
other people
and in our country it's the elections
and
racial protests and also wildfires of
here on my side of the country
so there's just like a lot of
uncertainty in the world
and a lot of anxiety that comes from
that uncertainty
and so i've been doing a lot of training
around that and i think it's so
important for us
to become present with that uncertainty
and anxiety
and what i've learned is that we can
train
in that it doesn't have to be a thing
that shuts us down
or gets us spinning out of control what
i've learned
is first of all we all have uncertainty
every day of our lives and we have some
habitual ways of responding to that
you know smoking and all the things that
i've talked about procrastination
eating nachos would be some good
examples of that
netflix and youtube and social media and
email
all the things that we're familiar with
these are our habitual responses
to uncertainty to a feeling of
uncertainty in our heart of like i'm not
sure
how things are going and the way that we
usually feel that is some kind of tug on
our heart
or almost like a elevator is dropping
out from under our feet
it's this feeling of groundlessness and
again we have habitual responses
that we've been training ourselves in
for years for our whole lives
and those aren't always helpful
sometimes they are sometimes they're not
but they're automatic and so we don't
have choice because we have trained
ourselves to do it automatically when
uncertainty arises
and right now you'll see yourself again
i mentioned going to
amazon and ordering a bunch of things
going to netflix or
youtube or whatever it is whatever thing
that you go to
you'll notice yourself doing it more now
than ever before
that's a highlight of your habitual
response
because the uncertainty is so intense
the anxieties
is so intense in our lives right now and
so what i would say
is that this is the best time to train
this is the most important time to train
because it's so in our faces that we
can't avoid it
and so why not turn towards it and
welcome it and open up to it and
practice with it
and the practice that i have been
training people in and training myself
in
i think is so helpful is to drop into
the body when you're feeling it and
you notice you're feeling it because
you're going to your habitual
responses all of the things that i've
mentioned drop into the body and drop
your
attention into bodily sensations so just
notice
what you're feeling in your chest and
your stomach and your throat
and usually it's somewhere around the
chest area you'll feel like a tightening
or a tug or a pain or an energy
and the energy itself of uncertainty is
not a problem
and what we can do is turn towards it
mindfully and be with it with
a curiosity when we have curiosity with
us it's no longer something we need to
run from
or get rid of it's actually just
completely fine it's just an energy in
our body
and we can just be curious wanting to
know more and being open with it
and if you train with it in this way and
we have so many opportunities to train
right now it's a very very rich training
ground right now
you can actually learn to be completely
comfortable with uncertainty
and not need to run to habitual patterns
and what that means is you're now
in choice and you can still eat the
nachos you can still do all of the usual
things and that's nothing wrong with
those but you also can
decide to stay in the discomfort to do
the hard thing to turn
towards the thing you're turning away
from to say sorry
to someone all of those things are now
available to you when you
practice with it in this way yeah this
is uh
this is a practice that is certainly
very present for me at the moment
as uh if you can hear the the ice
smashing in the background
as uh before recording the only place
that i have
reliable wi-fi is in the attic of a
restaurant which seems to be in
rush hour right now so it's
immediately present for me it's how to
not compulsively go into the thought
loops and the
default behaviors that we use as
temporary painkillers yeah and
how we can learn to be more comfortable
with
the discomfort and certainly
expect to have greater and greater need
of that in the upcoming months
with the not just unpredictability
that is naturally occurring but the sort
of engineered
spectacle and theater of uncertainty
yes they would call it in uh the
business context
fear uncertainty and doubt yep that's
fun when people are selling fud which is
certainly the job of many political
campaigns with respect to their evidence
is fear uncertainty and doubt so whether
by choice or by force people will be
or by chance people will be dealing with
a lot of uncertainty are there any other
approaches that you found particularly
helpful
or mantras any type of self-talk
anything at all
really that you've found helpful for
surfing the chaos that is part of life
and maybe more acutely now than ever
for a lot of people a part of their
daily or weekly experience
there's a quote actually by choking
trump who you might be familiar with
he's a tibetan buddhist master and he
has this quote which is the bad news
is that you're falling through the air
with no parachute
so you can feel already like in the
middle of this quote you can feel
the intense like groundlessness the
intense anxiety that might arise
but the second part of his quote is so
the bad news is that you're falling
through the air with no parachute the
good
news is there's no ground below and i
really love that quote because it just
makes you realize you're not in danger
even though it feels
completely groundless and you can relax
in that kind of like
visual picture right you can just relax
in the middle of that
and what i've found is available to us
if you can just relax with the
uncertainty that's arising
even anxiety is there's like an openness
that's available to us that's always
there
and it's just really liberating and so
what i've done is actually
started to train myself and and now i
train other people in it
of setting myself these practice periods
of like let's say an hour or half an
hour
of meaningful work that i normally would
turn away from some big project
that's really meaningful to me i'll set
that as like my practice period where
i'm intentionally inducing
uncertainty in myself and i'll actually
just set an attention in the beginning
the reason why i'm doing this the thing
that i care about and then i'll let
myself
practice with this and i'll notice that
i'm trying to go towards my email
and just sit with the uncertainty of it
and then just go move
towards the actual doing with this kind
of openness
so i'll do it as a daily practice but
also practice pretty much
all the time whenever anxiety or
uncertainty comes up
and it just becomes like no big deal so
that's another phrase that really helps
me is no big deal
it's just an energy of uncertainty it's
not not a big deal
so those are the ways that i practice
with it right now i love the
the good news bad news the rather bad
news bad news you're falling through the
air with no parachute
good news ground that's spectacular
leo leo finally on the podcast
twitter zen underscore habits and of
course
zenhabits.net all things simplicity
such a pleasure to have you in
conversation
and to be able to explore all these
things i always
love asking questions of friends who
otherwise would feel like they were
being interrogated in
weird format but it works is there
anything else that you would like to
to add or say or share with people
before we wrap
up anything that you would like people
to take a look at or
consider anything at all well i have to
say too that this is
just a tremendous honor just really love
the work you're doing in the world tim
so thank you for having me on this but
yeah the thing that i would leave
people with is you know sometimes in
this
crazy world that we're we're in right
now
we have the luxury of finding ourselves
in it can be really difficult
the anxiety can be so hard that's really
hard to practice with it
so when you find yourself in that place
where
you're just wanting to shut down and
curl up in a ball and like
it's just too hard to practice with in
this way that i've just talked about
just bring back
that self-compassion that i just that we
talked about earlier
it's just this is an important time to
just take care of yourself give yourself
some compassion
give yourself a warm bath have some hot
tea
let yourself eat the nachos it's okay
yeah it's it's such an important time to
take care of ourselves
yeah the world will be hard enough on
you without you beating yourself up
lady luck or fortune does not need your
help flagellating you
that's right you have challenges and
obstacles enough and
good lessons good medicine for right now
and
to everybody listening of course i will
include
links to everything we've discussed to
leo's work to
resources on unschooling everything else
the
zen precepts that we
discussed at one point and much more
will all be at
tim.blog forward slash podcast and leo
thank you
once again i really appreciate you
making the time thank you tim and to
everybody out there until next time
thank you
for listening hey guys this is tim again
just a few more things before you take
off
number one this is five bullet friday
do you want to get a short email from me
would you enjoy getting a short email
from me every friday
that provides a little morsel of fun
before the weekend and
five bullet friday is a very short email
where i share the coolest things i've
found or that i've been pondering
over the week that could include
favorite new albums that i've discovered
it could include
gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of
weird [ __ ] that i've somehow dug up
in the the world of the esoteric as i do
it could include
favorite articles that i've read and
that i've shared with
my close friends for instance and it's
very short it's just
a little tiny bite of goodness before
you head off
for the weekend so if you want to
receive that check it out
just go to four hourworkweek.com that's
fourhourworkweek.com all spelled out and
just drop in
your email and you will get the very
next one and if you sign up
i hope you enjoy it this episode is
brought to you by
givewell.org tis the season of giving
and you've got this week and next
to make your charitable donations before
we close the books on 2020
2021 is just around the corner that's
why i've been talking to you on this
podcast about givewell.org
for more than 10 years givewell.org has
helped donors find the charities and
projects that save
and improve lives most per dollar here's
how
givewell dedicates more than 20 000
hours a year to researching charitable
organizations
and hand-picks a few of the highest
impact evidence-backed
charities i recommend givral.org and
they shared a note with me
which is just incredible and here it is
quote here are the data they sent me a
spreadsheet
we have from organic donations that
cited tim over the past few years
transactions that specifically cited tim
ferriss sum to 133
040.74 we estimate that those donations
will save
15 to 24 lives how did this happen
i suspect that a lot of these donations
came from my interview with will
mccaskill who really knows what he's
talking about when it comes to effective
giving he's a philosopher
ethicist and one of the originators of
the effective altruism movement
he is an associate professor in
philosophy at oxford
that is the university of oxford and a
researcher at the global priorities
institute at oxford just a great guy
overall
and in our podcast together he
recommended givewell
by far as one of the best places to give
if you want to make an impact especially
if
you're busy it came to his mind
immediately all of their research is
publicly available for free
on their website and more importantly
givewell never takes any fees so all of
your tax deductible donations are given
to the charity you choose
since 2010 givewell has helped more than
50 000 donors direct more than 500
million dollars
to the most effective charities these
donations will save more than 75 000
lives
and improve the lives of millions more
you only have a few days left
to make tax-deductible donations before
the new year
so go right now and when you make your
first donation to give well
your gift will be matched up to 250
just go to givewell.org tim
and pick podcast and tim ferriss at
checkout you got to do those things so
they can track it
this matching offer is good for as long
as funds last
so the race goes to the swift he
who hesitates or she who has dates is
lost get your first donation matched
up to 250 at givewell.org
tim and select podcast and tim ferriss
at checkout one more time
definitely take a look at this
givewell.org
tim this episode is brought to you by
tonal
t-o-n-a-l i'm super excited about this
one
and i was skeptical of it in the
beginning tonal
quote total is the world's most
intelligent home gym and personal
trainer end quote that's the tagline
from their website folks to give you the
one sentence summary and
this device it's really a system is
perfect for anyone looking to take their
homework out to the next level or
someone who just wants to get maximum
bang for the buck
in a tiny tiny footprint of space
tonal is precision engineered to be the
world's most advanced strength studio
and personal trainer it uses
breakthrough technology of all different
types
to help get you stronger faster i was
introduced to total by three different
friends
all of them are tech savvy one of them
is a former competitive skier
who's doubled his strength in a number
of movements using tonal even though
he has a long athletic background
and i'll paint a picture for you by
eliminating traditional metal weights
dumbbells and barbells total can deliver
200 pounds of resistance which doesn't
sound like a lot but it's actually
it feels like a lot more at the high end
in a device smaller than a flat screen
tv and you can perform at least 150
different exercises and these different
technologies are exclusive to tonal and
you can dial weights
up and down with the touch of a button
in one pound increments
using magnets and electricity so the
movement is extremely smooth
and even though i have a home gym
already in my garage
i'm still getting a tonal installed i've
used
tonal for multiple workouts now to do
things i just cannot do
in my home gym such as the chop and lift
exercises from
four hour body all sorts of cable
exercises that would usually
involve much much bigger piece of
equipment eccentric
training for instance you can do to give
a simple example
bicep curls where you are lifting let's
just say
20 pounds in each hand up and then total
will automatically
increase the weight because you can
lower more than you can lift
to say 25 or 30 pounds on the way down
and i do
kettlebell swings i do all sorts of
deadlifts this that the other thing and
after one workout
on tonal focusing on pulling i was
blasted for a full
week it's really incredible what you can
do with eccentrics
they also have all sorts of other really
really cool
advantage that you can apply to any of
your favorite movements
tonal learns from your strength and
provides suggested weight
recommendations for every move with
detailed progress reports to help you
see your strengths grow
total also has a growing library of
expert led workouts by motivating
coaches from strength training
to cardio so you can do really just
about everything every program is
personalized to your body
using artificial intelligence and other
aspects
of the engineering and smart features
check your form in real time just like a
personal trainer
so try it out try tonal at least check
it out watch
the videos on youtube and see if you can
pick out a familiar voice
it's not me i'll say that but try tonal
the world's smartest home gym
for 30 days in your home and if you
don't love it you can return it for a
full refund
so visit www.tonal.com for 100
off of smart accessories when you use
promo code tim
tim at checkout that's www dot
to promo code tim
be your strongest
you